the new red table talk tackles female
alcoholism
and jada shares her own struggles with
addiction
ecstasy alcohol
wheat whoa i could drink
almost anybody under the table damn
yeah well specifically now will's a
light weight
jada doesn't hold back admitting on red
table talk that using ecstasy could have
killed her career
excuse me hey
i had one incident on nutty professor i
passed out
it was a bad batch of ecstasy
and i told everybody i must have had old
medication in a vitamin bottle
e.t was with a then 24 year old jada
just prior to the film's 1996 premiere
some wild crazy things happening on the
set no
it's pretty easy going very calm
she also revealed debbie allen who
directed her in the 90s sitcom
a different world once voiced concern
over her drinking
don't think that when i was at debbie
allen throwing up all over her house
that she wasn't like hey i'm a walking
miracle
so why reveal this now when kevin
visited the smiths at home the ladies
told him
putting it all out there actually makes
them closer
that's kind of how it started i think
you said something like who were you
before you were my mother i was like
that's a conversation but there's been
so much healing